Why is a square root called a square root?
Why does it have the word square in it?
Also, why does a number to the power of two get called a square?
I'll explain, but pause the video if you want to try figuring it out yourself first.
Okay, here's the answer.
If you square a number you basically multiply it by itself,
so for example four squared is four timesfour, which equals 16.
Now if you draw this on a graph and put the first four on the horizontal axis and the second four on the vertical axis,
You actually get a square which has got an area 16 because it's four times four.
So that's where the word square comes from in
squared and square root.
Basically when you do a square root of a number let's say 20,
You're saying, if I have a square with the area of 20, what's the length of one of the sides? In this case
In this case, it's 4.47 blah blah blah...
Now some numbers are called perfect squares, which means when you square root them the answer is a whole number.
So the square root of 16 is 4, so 16 is a perfect square.
If the number isn't a perfect square like 20, then the square root is a decimal like 4.472
Blah-Blah-Blah-Blah-Blah, so 20 isn't a perfect square.
Here's another interesting thing,
the answer to square root is always a little imprecise, because there are actually two answers.
A positive and a negative one, so the square root of 16 is actually both plus 4 and minus 4.
This is because - 4 Squared also gives you 16 because it's -4 x -4 and a negative number times a negative number equals a positive number.
So you don't know which one it is so people normally just take the positive
and this is interesting because it's also why you can never have the square root of a negative number.
This is because nothing times itself makes a negative number
It's also like having a square with a negative area
which you can in fact get if you look at our graph it would come from 4 x -4
or -4 x 4 but -4 and 4 are different numbers
so it can't be the answer to a square root
and beyond that when you've got a number to the power of three it's called a cube,  because you multiply it by itself three times
extending it out into the third dimension
and the opposite of this is called the cube root.
Then also if you've got a number to the power of four you extend it out into the fourth dimension,
but this is totally hard to draw or even imagine so you kind of just have to trust the maths.
So this is why it's called the square root.
I also looked up where the word root comes from in Square root and the root of that word is from the Roman word
Radix which is also. Why the symbol for square root is called a radical.
Who knew?